en vient à cette mobilisation du
personnel des aéroports parisiens il
entame aujourd'hui une grève à orly
roissy
les salariés protestent à l'appel des
syndicats contre les baisses de salaires
des conséquences du plan d'adaptation
des contrats de travail pour pallier la
crise du coït 19
la grève était prévue du 1er au 5
juillet mais le personnel a souhaité
lancer des actions a dès ce week end on
retrouve en direct de roissy notre
reporter david kelly show david bonjour
le secteur aérien continue donc de
panser ses plaies après une année
désastreuse
beaucoup de gens sont mobilisés quel est
le programme de la journée a bien écouté
doha la mobilisation est en tout cas au
rendez vous hri se sont donné rendez
vous à cette heure devant le terminal 2
heures un dieu de l'aéroport de roissy à
charles de gaulle pour plusieurs actions
eu une opération notamment à l'intérieur
même de l'aéroport ils ont leur ils ont
bloqué à plusieurs usages et un pour
protester contre ce fameux pacte est là
le cortège poursuit sa course vers le
siège social aide à des pépins finale de
cette mobilisation d'autres opérations
auront lieu au cours de la journée
notamment une opération escargot qui se
tiendra tout autour dû au froid si paul
en tout cas ces manifestants qu est-ce
qu il avait clamé bien c'est le retrait
de ce plan d'adaptation des contrats de
travail ils impactent directement sur
leur salaire puisqu'il va modifier ou
supprimer certaines indemnités ça
concerne environ 5200 un salarié avec
l'aéroport d'orly et l'aéroport de
roissy un charles de gaulle ces pactes
ont été créés par la direction en raison
de la pandémie ducobu 19 ski plutôt
incompréhensible pour la plupart des
salariés présents ici puisque adp
investi 1,6 milliard d'euros à dans des
aéroports à l'étranger je vous propose
d'écouter plusieurs leaders syndicaux à
l'initiative de cette mobilisation
nous sommes tous rassemblés en grève
contre
plan du de la direction d'aéroports de
paris appelé pacte qui remet en cause a
minima un mois de salaire qui nous
supprime un mois de salaire les choix
stratégiques de l'entreprise de nos
dirigeants
je rends période de crise c'est un petit
peu je pense décalé par rapport à ce qui
se passe et vouloir nous faire payer les
choix ils ont fait d'investir à
l'étranger des choix foire quand on
regarde bien pour l'instant tout cas à
court terme
c'est complètement dégueulasse et
irresponsable elle c'est du mépris c'est
profondément méprisant
parce que de nous dire que le ministre
ou parce que c'est pas le ministre qui
va nous recevoir bien entendu c'est son
cabinet où ses acolytes on va dire aimer
de dire qu'il n'a pas le temps de
recevoir
ben c'est une mais c'est une forme de
mépris comme on voit que monsieur de
romanet qui nous dit à la télé qui
versera 100 et sociales moi j'ai jamais
reçu un courrier dernièrement de
monsieur dormait qui faisait que les
ressources dans les sources syndicales
donc c'est par ce type de danon ce qu'on
apprend qu'on nous écoute que les
entends ce qu'est ce qui est pas
vraiment ce qu'on appelle du dialogue
social voilà vous l'avez entendu on
demande de la considération mais aussi
une certaine forme de discussion c'est
le projet initial si vous voulez des
organisations syndicales qui réclament
des assemblées générales afin de pouvoir
a discuté et éviter évidemment est
évidemment s et es grève etc
ces mobilisations mais pour l'instant le
gouvernement fait la sourde oreille et
lé dirigeant également voilà tout le
problème et voilà tout l'objet de cette
manifestation qui va terminer sa course
devant le siège social un des défis en
tout cas je vous le disais la
mobilisation est au rendez-vous cadré
par un important dispositif de sécurité
plusieurs tensions ont éclaté ce matin
au sein même de l'aéroport mais vite
retombé et pour le moment le portage se
déroule dans la tranquillité dans une
ambiance plutôt festive et musicale
merci beaucoup david kelly fait pour
toutes ces précisions
en direct de l'aéroport de roissy